I know what you're thinking.
Noah Flynn is stupid hot,
but Lee and I developed
a list of friendship rules.
Lee was responsible for
rule number nine,
which specifically states:
"Relatives
of your best friend
are totally off-limits."
I know that we don't really
see eye to eye on things,
but I'm… I'm desperate.
So, maybe if you could just
stop by the booth
for a little…
I don't know. I just…
It would mean a lot to me.
I know that you were
probably expecting Olivia,
so we don't have to do
anything
if you don't want to.
Erm, truth be told, I've
never kissed anyone before.
It's not that I haven't
wanted to,
don't get me wrong.
Sophomore year spring fling,
I was dancing
with Randy Melrose.
You know,
a romantic song came on.
I was like:
"What will happen?",
but… Until it just didn't--
I cannot just be another one
of your conquests.
Is that
what you think of me?
That's what everyone thinks
of you.
Don't forget we're going out
on Saturday
to celebrate your big news.
We don't have to, mum.
Of course we do!
It's not every day
you get accepted
to an Ivy League school.
Which school?
Harvard.
Are you shitting me?
That's amazing!
Ok.
Here's
how this is going to work.
Rules.
If we do this,
nobody can know.
Ok?
At least until… I figure out
a way to tell Lee.
It has to be that way.
Is there something going on
between you two?
No, no. Nothing is going on.
Ok.
What the fuck?
Lee? I can explain.
-Unbelievable.
-Wait, no!
Stay here, please.
You were never meant
to find out this way.
Seems like I was never
meant to find out
at all, doesn't it?
Hey, lay off her, Lee.
It's not like
it's all Elle's fault.
You're trying to
tell me that
you two
have not slept together?
I knew it.
So you really just have been
fucking my brother
and lying to me.
You're acting
like a hurt little bitch!
-Noah, get off him!
-Stop!
Why did you come
downstairs?
I told you to stay inside!
It's like you wanted
to make things worse!
What is wrong with you?
You cannot pin
all this on me.
Just leave me alone.
No problem.
Elle.
I think you're next up.
I'm sorry, Noah.
I can't.
Elle, wait. Please.
Elle.
Why?
Because I love you.
Standing here,
in front of everyone,
I'm telling you
that I love you.
I'm sorry.
I just…
I can't keep hurting people
that I care about
because of you.
I was wrong.
But I'd be lying to you
again
if I didn't tell you that
I love him
with every bit of my heart.
Sitting here in front of…
no one in particular,
I'm saying I love you.
And I love you.
Goodbye.
Come on, Shelly.
Don't say it like that.
I'll see you soon
and you can come and visit.
-We can make this work.
-Ok, stop.
And don't turn back
for a final wave.
That is way too cheesy
and romantic.
Even for me.
Why were you so upset
when you left?
I guess I was looking at
this whole life that you
have out there without me
and I'm…
I'm definitely not used to
seeing you around
all those college girls.
Elle, I told you Chloe's
just a friend.
I want to believe you.
There's no reason
you shouldn't.
If you're telling me
that nothing has happened,
then I believe you.
I just wanted
to wish you luck
for your competition
tomorrow.
You remembered.
Of course I remembered.
I wish I could be there.
[inaudible]
that you kissed him,
but I need you
to tell me anything.
Do you love him?
Please try to remember
what I'm about to say.
It's you, Noah.
It's always been you.
When you get off
the wait list for Harvard,
maybe you and I
could go off campus
and get an apartment
together.
Wait, you mean like…
Like get our own place?
Yeah. Look.
I've been online all day.
There are some
pretty cool places.
I got off the wait list.
Harvard.
What?
I thought you could use
a night in.
You deserve it.
What's wrong?
I have this thing with Lee
and we've been planning it
for weeks--
Please don't tell me
it's a bucket list thing.
I'm sorry. I feel horrible.
You're actually going to go?
I made you dinner.
It's not like I want to go,
Noah.
We're going to be in Boston
together all next year.
I just feel like I'm leaving
him all alone at Berkeley.
Me asking you to come
to Boston isn't some, like,
evil plot to make you leave
Lee behind.
No. I'm not… That's not
what I'm saying at all.
Listen, I'm going to be back
in an hour, ok?
I swear.
Alright.
Do whatever you want.
You know what? I…
I don't like fighting.
Me neither.
But I'll fight for you.
I'll fight for you, too.
You know
what I keep thinking about?
Why the guy that you kissed
in front of the whole world
is wearing the costume
that you asked me to wear.
-Why is he wearing it?
-Noah!
You always just pull things
way out of proportion.
It's very clear that he's
still after you and if you--
He's not. Nothing's going on
between Marco and me.
If you think that
he's not still after you,
then you're being naïve.
It's embarrassing.
You still want Elle.
And everybody here
knows that.
I said shut up.
The sooner you get that
into your thick skull,
the sooner you can--
Noah!
I'm not doing this.
I know better than trying
to stop you going to Boston.
But, if you do decide to go,
it's not going to be
with me.
So, that's… it?
The fact that we love
each other means nothing?
I do love you, but…
Maybe sometimes
loving each other
just isn't enough.
-Hey Shelly.
-Hi Noah.
It's been a long time.
You seem so grown up.
I was going to say
the same thing about you.
You know, if feels like
yesterday you were just
crashing your scooter down
the driveway.
Well, I'm a much better
driver now.
Oh.
I even have
my own motorcycle.
Really?
Ok, well.
I mean,
when I'm in town again,
we should go
for a ride together.
I mean, if you'd like that.
I would like that.
That sounds fun.
Well, I've got to…
I've got to go and see
some friends
and I've got
an early flight, so…
No, of course.
But I'll…
No, no. I'll call you, ok?
Sure.
Yeah, if you've got time.
I've got time.
-I'm going to go.
-Ok.
-Alright.
-I'll see you later.
-Ok.
-See you. Ok, bye.
-Bye.